part of our commitment here at cbs news
is stopping the stigma around mental
health
we're bringing you the story of a
mother-daughter duo who are donating
books to raise awareness
sonja watson and her daughter rachel
sidaway co-wrote an impossible life
it details wasston's struggle with
bipolar disorder and how it affected her
family and her friends
before the pandemic the pair traveled to
libraries all around the country
dr tara narula has been following their
story joins us now good morning to you
tara can't wait to meet them
good morning gail we spoke to sonia and
rachel
right before the pandemic shut down
libraries and halted travel
but that hasn't stopped them from
sharing this message
mental health does not discriminate
based on location
education or socioeconomic status it can
affect
anyone the mother and daughter's story
is one of love
hope and triumph you just
feel like you can't breathe it becomes
so painful
that you no longer see your children
your husband
and all it is is left as this pain sonia
wasden has struggled with bipolar
disorder
for most of her life you said that you
stopped looking at death with sympathy
and started looking at death with envy
yeah i wanted to die i was desperate
to get relief of the pain and that's the
only way i saw out
at 35 the mother of three was forced
into a psychiatric hospital
my husband had hit rock bottom and
said this is it we've got to get her in
the hospital and i refused to go
and the doctors asked me do you have
thoughts of suicide
and i said well of course just like you
do and when he said well how many times
do you think of suicide
a day and i thought well just the
average amount just as often as you do
and so i was admitted against my will
was that the turning point for you in
terms of starting to get on a road
towards
treatment yes they started giving me
medicine
and that's when they made me face my
diagnosis that i was bipolar
and i did rachel is the oldest
of sonia's children did you know that
your mother was sick
growing up all i knew was my mom was
really
fun and then she'd get really sad
we were all aware she tried to take her
own life but because we knew ultimately
she loved us and we are best friends i
could see her as a person
going through something hard and almost
feel more
compassion for her as my best friend as
my mother i loved instead of
letting it be traumatizing we all feel
like we're
this tight little army group that were
in a foxhole together and we came
out stronger for it together the
mother-daughter duo wrote
an impossible life sharing their story
of survival
at what point did you finally decide it
was time
to reveal your illness after my
attempted
suicide i was taken to the hospital
where my husband was ceo
and a leading psychiatrist there told
him never bring her back to this
hospital again
take her where no one knows you guys and
i felt shame
and embarrassed and there was like
almost a fire that got lit in me of
i am not going to hide anymore the truth
needs to be told
and they've gone beyond just telling the
truth before the pandemic hit
they traveled more than 32 000 miles on
their own dime to 42 states
and have donated more than 500 books
since then they have mailed more than
100 books to libraries that have
reopened
we're here to donate our story and to
raise mental health awareness one local
library at a time
they made something beautiful out of the
pain both for
rachel and sonya's relationship it was
so healing
when i was 16 i found my mom's suicide
now and
i was really angry i thought it was
selfish that she'd want to leave
me and my entire family just like that
and after writing this book with her i
have a better understanding of the pain
she went through
and for those who have read the book oh
my god
like kimberly guin who met sonia for the
first time
at brooklyn public library reading
sonia's book was very powerful in the
sense that
it enabled me to
forgive myself it enabled me to
have more compassion for myself for the
mistakes i made because
obviously you don't choose this the book
helped me
understand what my family members would
have gone through
but most importantly it gave me hope by
offering hope
sonia has found purpose in her suffering
to show readers what was once
an impossible life is now a possible one
how are you feeling now good i have a
beautiful life now my marriage of 27
years is going strong i have good
relationships with all my children
i don't stay in bed all day anymore yes
i have a mental illness and yes i have
moments of pain
and anxiety and difficulty it's a
lifelong illness that i have to manage
but i can have a life worth living too
wow sonia's father was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder
later in life and died by suicide one of
her sons
was also diagnosed with bipolar disorder
and is doing well
the most important thing they told us is
to keep talking about it especially now
when
many feel so isolated or alone if you or
someone you know is in crisis
contact the national suicide prevention
lifeline at 1-800-273-8255 and you see
the effect of people
talking and coming out and telling their
story how healing it is for the person
involved for the family
and for anyone who's read this book but
bravo to sonia though when they go to
her husband's hospital and they said
next time go someplace where they don't
know and she goes no
you can't do that to me that's tara that
was very powerful it's going to help a
lot of people
all right thank you tara